العملات المشفرة التي تزيد قيمتها عن عقد من
الزمان تساوي تريليونات الدولارات أكثر
من إجمالي الناتج المحلي لإيطاليا
وبالنسبة للعديد من العملات المشفرة فهي مستقبل
المال ولكن على عكس الوقت الحالي للمال ، فإن
الأموال الموجودة في جيبك حظًا سعيدًا في
محاولة العثور على مكان لشراء كوب من
القهوة معها اعتمادًا على من تسأله
عن العملة المشفرة هو أكبر تحول في المال منذ
اختراع الورق أو أكبر عملية احتيال
منذ أن كان لدى تشارلز بونزي طابعًا بريديًا
يريد بيعه لك ، لذا دعنا نتحدث
عن كيفية عمله ، فنحن نعلم أن هناك
العديد من الأنواع المختلفة  من العملات المشفرة ، يوجد
البيتكوين الأكثر شهرة والأكثر
قيمة من بين جميع العملات المشفرة ، ثم لديك
جميع العملات المعدنية مثل دوجكوين ، وهناك
الآلاف من هذه العملات المشفرة الأصغر التي
تتقلب قيمتها بشكل كبير حيث
يتم سك العملات الجديدة كل يوم ، ثم هناك
الإيثيريوم الذي مكّن من ظهور
nfts الفن الرقمي والمقتنيات التي
يتم تداولها على blockchain هذه
الشبكة اللامركزية من أجهزة الكمبيوتر التي
تتحقق من المعاملات ولكن هناك شيء
آخر ملزم  العملات المشفرة في الوقت الحالي
هي أنها ليست في الواقع
أوقات المعاملات المفيدة بطيئة بالنسبة لعملة البيتكوين ،
فقد يستغرق الأمر ما يصل إلى 20 دقيقة حتى
تتم معاملة واحدة علاوة
على ذلك ، فسوف تدفع رسومًا باهظة الثمن ،
لذا إذا لم تكن العملات المشفرة في الواقع
هذا مفيد كعملة ،
فلماذا لا تكون العملات المشفرة ذات قيمة
كبيرة مدعومة بأي شيء
سوى التكنولوجيا الأساسية
وإيمان الناس بها يعتقد الكثير من
الناس أن العملة المشفرة
ستجعلهم أغنياء
ويؤمن الآخرون بما يمكنك تسميته
بالتكنولوجيا التحررية.
تم تصميم الإيمان بهذه الشبكات اللامركزية
عبر بنك مركزي أو
عملة مشفرة للشركة
لتمكين الفرد من فكرة أنه
البنك وأنهم هم
حوكمة هذه العملة
المشفرة التي من المفترض أن
يحكمها الناس وأن تنتمي إلى
يقول الناس لكن النقاد إن كل هذا الحديث
عن توسيع الوصول إلى إرسال الأموال
هو مجرد حديث منذ أن عدنا  لدى ady
كل هذه الطرق الفعالة لشراء فنجان
من القهوة ، لماذا تضيف أخرى لا توجد
استخدامات عملية للعملات المشفرة ، 99 من
المعاملات تستخدم فقط عملة مشفرة
لشراء واحدة أخرى وليس عن طريق السلع وليس
الخدمات ، إنها مجرد فقاعة مرجعية تحقق
ذاتها.  لا يوجد ارتباط
بأي شيء في العالم الحقيقي ، هناك مخاوف أخرى من
أن الشبكات التي تعمل على تشغيل
العملات المشفرة تستخدم الطاقة ، حيث يستهلك الكثير من هذه الطاقة من قبل nft واحد في المتوسط يستخدم نفس القدر من الطاقة مث
القيادة لمسافة 500 ميل في السيارة ومع ذلك يت
استثمار مليارات ال
ولارات  لا تزال
الحكومات نفسها تتطلع إلى
إطلاق عملات رقمية خاصة بها
للتنافس مع العملات المشفرة بينما تقوم في نفس
الوقت بكتابة تشريعات لتنظيمها ،
لذا الآن مع
دخول العملات المشفرة شديدة التقلب إلى التيار الرئيسي ،
لا تزال هناك أسئلة أكثر من
الإجابات عما إذا كان هذا هو مستقبل المال  أم
أنها مجرد فقاعة ، هل
هي في أيدي الحكومة
أم يمكن تقييدها من قبل المنظمين
والإرادة  كنا ندفع ثمن
فنجان القهوة هذا في دوجي